We did a game, I think,
the last time you were on or --
We played a game called
"Two Truths and a Lie."
-Right.
-To see if you could tell
if I'm lying or not.
Like, right now
you're looking into my eyes.
See? You're doing --
Yeah, you're already
in my head already.
-You know that, right? Wow.
-I do know that.
What I'm wondering is
if you know it.
[ Chuckles ]
-See? Already, yeah.
I don't even know
what you're talking about.
This is fantastic.
But I'm going to break this --
You're not even blink--
You're not even blinking.
[ Laughs ]
Oh, you're real good.
Okay, all right.
Now I want to see if you can
tell two truths and a lie
and see if I can tell
which one is the lie.
-Okay, you're gonna try
and psych me?
-Yep. I'm already in your head.
-Yeah.
-Good luck with that, James.
-[ Laughs ]
-Okay, I wrote 'em down.
And I'm going to give each one
the same weight.
So I'm going to read
three things, right?
-Yep.
-One of these is a lie.
-Mm-hmm.
-And you're going to try
and figure out which one.
-See, already you're doing --
It's like a magician.
-Now I'm going to read
all three of them.
-I understand the rules!
Yeah, it's okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
One of them's a lie.
We got that already.
-No, you can't ask any questions
until I've read
all three of them.
That's the rule,
and I'll make 'em.
All right.
-Pfft!
-Number one. Okay, number one.
-Yeah.
I have a cow part
in my shoulder.
Number two.
I was a roller-skating waiter
at an A&W Root Beer stand.
-[ Laughs ]
-Number three. I have taken a
bubble bath in Oprah's bathtub.
[ Audience ohhs ]
♪♪♪♪
-She would never!
Um...
-So ask me anything you want.
-What'd they sell at A&W?
-Well, they sold root beer.
They sold all kinds
of hamburgers.
They sold hot dogs,
French fries.
-And you'd wheel yourself
out there in short shorts
and go give it?
-You would go to the car.
You would take their order
'cause we didn't have
speaker boxes at the time.
You would skate it in there,
give it to the
short-order cooks.
Then when it was ready,
you'd skate it back out there,
put it on their window.
-Did Oprah know
you took a bubble bath?
-Well, she has a two --
She has both floors
of the Water Tower in Chicago.
And there's a guest apartment
on one of the floors,
and it has everything there
that you could possibly want --
a bathtub, shower, everything.
-Bathtub and shower in Oprah's?
-Right.
-Why would you have a cow part
in your shoulder?
-Well, it's a surgical
procedure, and --
-Was it, like, a muscle thing,
or what is it?
-It's a tendon.
They put it in
if you hurt your shoulder,
like, rotator cuff or whatever.
They put it in there
to speed recovery.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow...
I think I did it.
-Moo!
-[ Laughs ]
All right. I think I broke you.
I don't know.
Tariq, do you think
you understand?
Do you think you know
which one's what?
-I do. I do.
-You guys think you know?
You guys think you know
which one's a lie?
[ Audience affirming ]
-I'm going to say...
[ Drum roll ]
[ Audience shouting ]
I'm going to say
number one is a lie.
You do not have a cow part
in your shoulder.
-I do have a cow part
in my shoulder.
[ Foghorn ]
-What?!
-It was installed March,
a year ago,
when I crashed a dirtbike
in my own driveway.
I broke six ribs
and blew up my shoulder.
-Oh. Man.
Are you going to tell me
which one was the lie?
-Do you want to know?
-Yes.
-What do you guys think?
[ Audience shouting ]
Okay, what's --
-Did you take a bubble bath
in Oprah's bathtub?
-I did --
-We'll be right back right --
No, I'm just kidding.
-I did not take a bath
in Oprah's bathtub.
-Dr. Phil McGraw, everybody!
Check your local listings
for "Dr. Phil."